So, we have these two festivals.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And these two attendees. Missy Music and Johnny Concert.
>> Yeah.
>> I get it. We want to add this
like column, or this field onto our attendee object.
>> Mm-hm.
>> I, I want to just add a field? But I feel like something special has
to happen to get it to talk to, you know, and know about festivals or.
>> Well that's what so great about creating relationships in Salesforce.
It's just as easy as everything else we've already been doing. So,
you can go to the Objects Setup and just create a new field.
>> New field?
>> Yep.
>> Oh, okay. Is this where the magic comes in in choosing a field type?
>> Right. And there's two types of relationship
fields in Salesforce. Lookup and Master Detail. we can
go into more detail about that later but,
why don't we choose master detail just for now.
>> Okay. You will tell me later?
>> I will, I promise.
>> So,
master detail relationship. Relationship makes sense, I like that and next.
okay. So I'm guessing. Yeah, I'm going to relate this to festival.
>> Exactly, nice.
>> Okay, so what's all this about?
>> So again this is just going to create the label
for this field that'll be on the record detail page.
>> This is like our column name over here?
>> Just like the column name, exactly.
>> And so festival is good Okay,
it auto-did that. That was nice. So description,
the name of the festival the attendee's going to.
>> Right.
>> Okay, what's this one all about? Child relationship name.
>> So again, that's just a unique API
name that's going to live in the database. It's more
for the code side of things, or if we
were trying to build something off of child records.
>> And then should I just leave everything else?
>> Leave everything else as default.
>> And
we'll add the fields to the page layout?
>> So, it's going to automatically add it to
the page layout because it's a required field.
>> So, what's going on with this? Add
custom related list. So, what this is going to
do is it's going to add a list of
attendees to the record or the festival record.
>> Okay.
>> just like how in Attendees you can see
which festival they're going to go to, when you go
to the festival record you'll see a list of
all the attendees that are going to this festival.
>>
Cool. And I can hit Save. oh, it's getting, it's getting mad at me.
>> So, it's throwing this error because with master detail, when you create
this relationship, it becomes a required field. And since there are already two
>> Required field means like the attendee needs to have a festival?
>> Exactly.
>> Okay.
>> And since there're already two attendees that were created, and
they aren't related to a festival, you can't create this relationship.
>> So, it's like protecting us from having
all these attendees that don't make sense anymore.
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> And so, the way to get around this is, let's create a
look up relationship first because, in that case it won't be a required field.
>> And then we can add them and then change it.
>> Exactly.
>> Okay.
>> So, let's go through that one more
time but choose look up relationship this time.